So what's RAID 1 reliability if we
do replace failed disks as soon as
possible?
We have the situation that both disks
are okay for this amount of time.
Then a disk fails, and then we have
only one okay disk for the mean time to
repair for one disk, so this is how long
does it take us to replace the disk?
After that,
both disks are okay again, and
then we again have this long
until the next failure.
So what's the mean time to data loss for
RAID 1 with two disks?
The question really is,
how many times can we have this
until we encounter the period when
a single disk has failed, and
during the time it takes to replace it,
another disk fails?
Well, it's equal to
the length of this interval.
This is how how long we survive
with both disks working, times,
how many times can we get this until
we encounter a repair period where
the second disk failed during it.
So, the question is really what's the
probability of the second disk failing
during the time to repair one disk.
Now, normally, to calculate this
probability, we would have to compute
the distribution for this function and
then see what's the probability for
this distribution being under MTTR 1,
and so on.
But when the time to repair
is a lot smaller then
the time to failure of a single disk,
then we can approximate this
probability of the second disk
failing during the MTTR for
the first disk simply as
the MTTR divided by the MTTF.
So, for example, if the MTTR is,
let's say, a single day, and
MTTF is 100 days, then
the probability of the second failure
during the repair period is
simply the length of the repair
period divided by the period that
we expected this to survive.
So for example, if the time to
repair is, for example, one day, and
the time to failure is, let's say,
a hundred days, then we can expect that
there is a one in 100 chance off of
this failing during the one day.
So now how many times can we repair
this before we encounter one of these?
Well, the number of
times we can try this
until we encounter a failure is
going to be 1 over this probability.
So what we finally get is this.
The mean time to data loss is
MTTF of a single disk squared,
divided by 2 times the mean
to repair for one disk.
How long does it take us to replace
the disk and copy the data on it so
that now we have a fully
functional RAID 1 array?
And as a reminder, this is how long
do we get a working array with
both these functional, and
this is how many times do we do a repair
until we can expect that the second
disk that is covering us during
the repair is going to fail on us.
Not that because the MTTF Is
much larger than the MTTR,
this is measured in years, usually,
this hopefully is hours or days.
It's just how long does it
take us to replace the disk.
This factor here is very,
very large, and now we get many,
many times the MTTF of
a single disk over 2.
This factor way larger than 2, which
means that the time to data loss with
a RAID 1 array with only two disks is
way higher than the time to data loss
for a single disk, which means that RAID
1 is dramatically improving reliability.